[Music]
okay everybody i am so so excited today
because i am joined by kara bono aka
gail carter and the girl from plainville
which is out tomorrow on hulu kara how
are you doing today great how are you
doing nice to meet you i like your tats
oh thank you i appreciate that um
no kara i'm so excited about this
project you're in and it's interesting
to prep for this interview i watched the
hbo dock on the story of michelle carter
and what i noticed though is that you're
playing gail carter so
i feel like that's almost the most
challenging part to take on because i
feel like there's less info on her how
did you approach
your portrayal of gail in that sense
well i really appreciate you raising the
question that way because that was
one of the things that we talked about
that gail carter
never gave an interview there's really
no information on her all we've seen
there's some pictures of her in the
courtroom she really avoided the
spotlight so in that regard we created
our fictionalized idea of michelle's mom
and um we you know tried to give her
uh certain limitations that we thought
that she she might have because try to
see how perhaps michelle
was in the situation that she's in maybe
what was that relationship like with her
mom so we tried to sort of piece those
two pieces together
right so that that makes sense and when
you're talking about michelle like
was there anything did you and elle
fanning have to like get on this like
same page like okay how are we going to
portray this relationship to kind of
make it something that would seem
realistic how did you guys kind of even
approach that
well um you know she's just remarkable
in how she just
prepared and transformed for for
michelle and i think that
um
[Music]
you know
i just kind of approached it from the
point of view as you know who is she as
as this mother to you know when we look
at the story in terms of the tragedy of
it right and there's nothing worse than
losing a child
um and then
from my point of view as a mother sort
of when you discover this terrifying
reality that your daughter might be
complicit in a murder over text you
don't even know who this person is you
start to think
what did i do who who
who is this person who who is my
daughter how did this happen and there's
a lot of self-blame
but then at the same time trying to
figure out is this person someone who
has limitations as a mother clearly she
tried to get her daughter some help
um but in the relationship between um
michelle and me i always felt like we
decided that they were unable to ever
really make a connection
despite really wanting to you know
really wanting to have those
heart-to-heart conversations really
wanting to
connect and that their
craft that they fell through
sure and that's a really good answer and
that that makes you wonder too when
you're thinking about how you're
approaching michelle here and that
relationship to you as an actress as
kara knowing that this case is so
controversial in that everybody has such
strong opinions about it and it's a very
gray case in my opinion so
how do you keep like are you separating
cara's belief about the case when you're
putting it to michelle or is there some
kind of blend in there maybe maybe
subconsciously
it's interesting you know i think like
most people who will tune into the show
as an audience member or anyone who's
aware of the case i think most people
will come with a preconceived idea or
judgment of who's
what happened and who's responsible and
everything and i think
what drew me to the project and what i
think they do
is done very well is this exploration of
the peeling back of the layers of each
of the characters
um the situation they found themselves
in the the role that technology played
and social media played
and
really trying to find the humanity in
everybody and the tragedy that it is for
everyone involved
um and then further you know exploring
um
you know also this was you know several
years ago and we have more information
about
the dangers of social media and
technology particularly on teenage girls
in this country i mean there's we i'm
sure we all have personal
anecdotes but there's you know studies
out there about it and it really sheds
light on on this topic that we really
have to start talking you know talking
more about
yeah absolutely and um i think it's cool
too it's like it's exciting for people
who are big fans of you to see you play
a role like this that's based off a real
person and you do an absolutely amazing
job now i have to ask too i was excited
to talk to you about because i love that
you're from the bronx born in the bronx
and i i'm not it's not as exciting that
i'm from white plains but not far away
so
is there anything it's close you know so
it's not as cool but is there anything
growing up in the bronx that you kind of
took into your acting career like is
there a swag that comes with that what
what
what comes with that
oh that's such a cool question um
well i think that
you know growing up in the bronx um well
my dad was a mechanic and
um i always had a job since i was like
11 years old so i always worked so i got
i think you know in a working class
neighborhood you get a very good work
ethic
you know you don't really complain you
just kind of do what you got to do and
um
kind of um it's pretty diverse so you're
you know you grow up with a lot of
different kinds of people so the world's
sort of at your doorstep in that regard
and you know get rid of my bronx accent
but i pull it out when i need it
hell yeah i love that so
also it's what's surreal talking to you
is that i'm currently watching mad men
for the first time as we speak i am on
season four so i'm i'm really looking at
you right now as faye miller so is that
roll
do you hold out the dearest two because
it was one that you were you know
nominated for an emmy it was at such a
time when that show was like at its peak
do you kind of keep that in a special
place yes i i loved playing dr fayne
miller it was one of my all-time
favorite roles i was a huge fan of the
show when i got the job i
was
beyond i remember pulling my car over on
the side of this canyon i was going up
when i got the offer and just jumping
out and being so excited um and it was
interesting you know when i think back
to that show it was just before you know
there was these
well there was twitter and stuff but i
think that it was really before social
media when everyone was kind of tweeting
about or talking about shows as they
were happening
but um
you know i worked with matt winer on
soprano so i feel like
i've been
i love every job i've done but i really
had special place in my heart for for
that era and who she was and she was
kind of ahead of her time
yeah definitely and speaking of just
your storied career now i feel like
karen wheeler you're like this is your
rockstar role it made you a rock star
which is awesome so i have to ask this
one my fans don't kill me but if you can
give one adjective for stranger things
season four just one what would you say
one adjective wow let's see they didn't
prepare me for this but
i would say darker
okay
i love it and everyone if you love
her for all her role she's on camera
check her out
tomorrow on the girl from plainville
it's on hulu it's an awesome story and
i'm excited to see you just crush it
here thank you so much for joining me
today i hope talking in the future
likewise thank you
thank you